Thank you for watching this video. If you liked it, please subscribe to our channel and give it a thumbs up.
Thank you for watching. If you liked it, please subscribe to our channel and give it a thumbs up.
Happy birthday to you, happy birthday to you, happy birthday dear grandma.
All right Kate, it's really good, this is really good, look at the weekend at Fat Daddy's
Friday night back in Blackstown.
Make a difference in the health and lives of the women of Pennsylvania.
We're there for your health, for your community.
Pennsylvania Department of Health, Tom Ridge Governor.
The new millennium is Vertical Horizon, Vertical Horizon, March 18th at Franklin and Martin.
She was there through my incarceration, I want to show the nation my appreciation.
You're my darling, and that's how you should be treated.
So you'll never forget the loving that you needed.
Put a left for the calling you needed.
Taking a beating, mission completed.
And I said I saw your night, this day program.
Have the time to mess around with your emotion.
But the feeling that I have for you is so strong.
Things have been so long and this could never be wrong.
You're my darling, and that's how you should be treated.
You can't get out.
When he gets out that far, stick it in front of his nose.
No, because he can't get out.
Oh no, that scene jumped.
Oh, she got me.
What was that?
You heard that bump and you thought something was going giddy.
He looks like an old bear right there.
Yeah, he's got this figured out.
You're going to get it.
2001.
And now we are beginning.
Team is coming up next.
Get ready.
Bubbles and Buttercup.
Her and Brick.
Dr. Snure and Stacey.
Are here to save the world.
All of them.
LuLu, Lugia, and more.
Rock tune music.
Little brother.
Thank you little sister.
Ooga Ooga.
Voldemort.
Oh gosh, I can't name them all.
See you in this episode.
Get Coco.
This whole thing because we're trying to cook a meal for the girls.
Dad, I was just going shopping to get some food.
Okay, I'll see ya.
But where are the girls?
Where'd they go?
Yeah, I'm already good today.
Okay.
Just around.
Not bad at all.
That's a little junk mail.
Kind of.
Don't.
Charging it.
Don't be mad at that when you need something.
My table?
Yeah, I do.
Something to shake the A.C.
This year's an issue today, Stacey.
A.C.
Parts?
I'm just about to write.
Here's a picture of the A.C.
Tell him about it.
Okay, Stacey.
These cards have a little locket thingamajig.
Stacey, where did you put those parts for the A.C.?
Stacey, whatcha doing?
I'm looking at my list to see.
Hmm.
Optional parts.
Yes, I did say that.
Which one?
The Bungalow.
Nothing.
And I went to eat.
I'll get that.
Farika's Pizzeria.
Plugs and Dad.
Okay.
How come I get the little C?
Okay, now.
Stacey, fly forward.
Fire missiles.
Okay.
Gun 1 demolished.
Now, I'm gonna turn around.
I'm gonna turn around.
And you use the sword.
And we'll both use the sword quickly on that other gun.
Last gun.
Um, Stacey.
We're finished with the mission.
I know, but it was funny when you blew that awesome guy out.
What are you doing, Stacey?
Check the mail.
Strange mail.
Hmm.
It says, come to the restaurant at 05 tonight.
It says, Farika's Pizzeria Disco Club.
It's there.
A disco club is.
What are you doing?
Such a rascal.
You're done with all your chores.
No, this isn't a chore.
It's just a workout.
It's just something I like to do.
I'm burning my hands.
If we have one.
Pikachu, you're awake, Stacey.
Oh, wow.
Got you now.
Soon, you will be our slaves forever.
You're a big sis.
Stacey, let's fight.
Everybody on the head except Dr. and Stacey.
Evil brother.
Hold those elbows.
I'm coming up.
In Dr. Snowden and Stacey's concert.
I want you to try to get me out of here.
Wait, I have to relax.
The stairs.
Oh, am I supposed to be behind the door?
You're supposed to say.
Again.
Oh, great.
Next Blooper.
While you just get out of the stairs.
Comes the last song.
Hope you like it.